Okay, so a 100 test cases passed in that tiny amount of times it took us to run.
And so one thing we could conclude is that since a 100 of test passed over read all
that the logic is solid but it turns out that this conclusion isn't really warranted.
Let's see if we can get the program to tell us why.
So I'm going to do here is print out a value indicating the number of bytes that was actually
read by the raw read system call and then we'll run our testing loop.
And what happens is every single time we called read, it read the full size of the file.
So our splay.py here--we can see that's 3121 bytes and the actual Unix read system call
always read that many bytes every time we call it.
So it ends being the case even though it's illegal for read to return less bytes than we asked it to read
is not actually doing this, so what we're going to need to do in order to test our logic
in any meaningful way is make it do that, and so the question is how to do that.
Well, one way to do that would be to go hack Mac OS so that sometimes doesn't read
all the file bytes that we asked and that is not very fun, so we're going to do something a little easier.
We're going to insert faults ourselves by calling a read fault injection file.
By calling a read function with fault injection is the function I already wrote here, so what you can see
that read with fault injection does is it has exactly the same interface as read
just a different filename, but what it's going to do is instead of reading the nbytes
that we asked for it's going to set the number of bytes to read to be a random number
between 1 and the number of fault bytes inclusive.
And so the +1 there means that instead of going from 0 to the number of bytes minus 1,
we;re going to test the range from 1 to the number of bytes, and that's what we want to do.
We don't want to return 0 because that indicates an end of file condition.
So now we're ready to run some tests.